This house, located in the beautiful
mountain village of Asago, Japan, is free.
Not “free-to-the-one-millionth-visitor free”.
Not free except for these terms
and conditions free. Just… free.
Some of the top amenities include:
These ruins of a 15th-century castle,
a mere 20-minute scenic drive away.
And everything from Cherry Blossom
trees, to a supermarket, post office,
and hair salon — all within walking distance.
Now, the building itself is no five-star hotel,
it could use more than a fresh coat of paint.
But at nearly 1,400 square feet,
with two stories, flush toilets,
and heating, there are worse
ways to spend zero dollars.
More remarkable, perhaps, is the fact
that this deal isn’t all that remarkable.
There are at least eight million such
abandoned homes across Japan — some free
and others effectively free — just
waiting for someone to claim them.
Maybe the island lifestyle is more your speed,
in which case you might be interested in
this one for about $5,000 U.S. dollars.
If you’re looking to splurge a bit, this
one could be yours for eleven grand.
The possibilities are endless.
You can have your pick between
about one in every seven houses,
including the land, 11% of the entire
country’s surface area — and there’s
no hurry — these numbers are
expected to double by 2033.
That’s right, in just ten years’ time, nearly
every third Japanese home will be vacant,
according to the country’s largest
economic research institute.
And while its population is among
the fastest shrinking in the world,
demography alone cannot explain
these strange real estate dynamics.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula. Watch
my 6-part exclusive series
and other Nebula Originals,
like “Great Cities” with the CuriosityStream
and Nebula bundle, all for just $15/year.
Broadly speaking, there are two ways
to make housing more affordable:
increase supply or decrease demand.
Japan, uniquely, does both.
For one, demography certainly doesn’t hurt.
Its population has been declining since 2010 and
is expected to return to 1970 levels
within the next twenty-five years.
Fewer people means fewer
households means fewer homes.
That’s on the demand side. But
supply is no less important.
To put it simply: Japan builds. like. crazy.
Tokyo proper, for instance, has a
population of about 14 million people.
New York City, a little less than 9. But
despite being only 1.6 times more populous,
Tokyo built four and a third
times as many houses in 2020.
Of course, as any Californian can tell you,
“just build more” is easier said than done.
Increasing supply is threatening
to the very parties responsible
for its approval — neighbors, city
councils, and local governments.
But that’s where the Japanese system excels.
During the late 80s and early 90s, the country
experienced a housing bubble that rivals 2008.
At one point, all the land in Japan was
valued four times higher than all of America,
despite being twenty-six times smaller in
land area — about the size of Montana alone.
After the market came crashing down,
the government made changes to prevent
the same thing from happening again.
The tiny difference that makes all
the difference is that, in Japan,
land policy is now mostly set at
the national, not local, level.
Its Ministry of Land, Infrastructure,
Transportation, and Tourism is less like, say,
the little-known Federal Maritime Commission,
and more akin to the all-powerful EPA.
It, rather than partial local governments
or even the legislature itself,
largely dictates the country’s
building codes, for example.
Cities are only permitted to
divide their land into zones.
The national government decides what
can and can’t be built in each one.
The United States has no fewer
than twenty-two thousand sets of
codes — each one with dozens of different zones.
The entire nation of Japan, meanwhile,
is divided into just twelve — total. And any
changes made to one of them applies everywhere.
Another seemingly minor difference with major
downstream effects is the way these zones work.
While a commercial zone in America typically
allows only commercial activity — things like
auto repair shops, movie theaters,
and strip malls — the same one in
Japan also allows for non-commercial
uses, like apartments and schools.
What this means is that developers are free, if
they want, to mix uses. That free house in Asago,
for instance, is about 30 feet from a hair
salon and a three-minute walk from a book store.
In Japan, your neighbors really have no
say over what you do with your property — a
degree of freedom that results in
some pretty quirky design choices.
On the tame end of the spectrum, there’s
the stuff of HOA nightmares: You might
find a traditional wooden house directly
adjacent to a modern, minimalist mansion.
Then there are the truly creative
ones: the Gothic tomato cottages,
transparent townhouses, and giant pyramids.
If you can dream it, it can surely be built.
One consequence is that Japan
produces more architects per
capita than any other country — and by a
wide margin — 5 times more than the U.K.,
7 times more than America,
and 11 times more than Canada.
It’s hard to imagine a better place
for young architects to experiment
than a nation of tiny homes free from
concerns about “neighborhood character”.
But wait a second. Four times as many new homes as
New York? These numbers aren’t just
impressive. They’re… too impressive.
Think about it this way: Here are
seven large, advanced economies.
This is each one’s total population.
And this is the number of new homes
each one builds in a typical year.
One country clearly stands out. How can it
be that Japan, with only 40% as many people,
builds almost as many new homes
each year as the United States?
We all know California is starved for housing,
but this is just crazy. The math doesn’t add up.
The solution to this puzzle, it turns out,
lies in the number of existing homes sold.
Now we can see that although the total number
of homes sold in each country — both new and
used — is roughly proportional to its population,
there’s a huge difference in composition.
The vast majority of American
home sales are second-hand,
whereas the vast majority of
Japanese home sales are brand new.
In fact, if we stretch the data out, we can
see that it’s almost the inverse of America.
And that’s Japan’s secret. The reason its
housing market is so fundamentally different.
It’s not just about national control of zoning,
it’s also an entirely different
perspective on what housing is.
In most advanced economies,
a house is an investment that doubles as
a place to live — a 401k you can sleep in.
In Japan, a house is a consumer good — not unlike
a car or a refrigerator — that
rapidly depreciates in value.
In a mere thirty years, the typical Japanese
home goes from brand-new to about
valuable as a CD player in 2023.
That’s no exaggeration. According
to the Ministry of Land,
even a reinforced-concrete apartment
has a lifespan of just 37 years.
Try to sell your house on the 38th year and
banks will tell you it’s worth zero dollars,
or less since the building has to be
demolished before a new one can be built.
As you can see here, used homes depreciate,
on average, over twice as
fast in Japan as in the U.S.
One reason for this is relatively
straightforward: earthquakes.
Not only do they destroy homes, but they
require periodic updates to building
codes to better prepare for the next one.
Newer buildings are considered much safer.
Another reason has to do with history.
Nearly a third of urban Japanese homes
were bombed during the Second World War,
creating a shortage of 4 million units.
And when private banks were unable
to keep up with demand for mortgages,
the government was forced to step in.
Starting in June of 1950, generously subsidized
interest rates were offered
to anyone in need of a home.
These millions of dollars of stimulus,
redirected from the war, helped pay
for nearly 20 million units by 2007.
But this overwhelming success came
with an unintended side-effect.
In the rush to house war-torn Japan,
building standards — even those of the
1950s — were haphazardly overlooked.
These were cheap, wooden houses with poor
insulation and sometimes major structural flaws.
Because of this, they tended to last
just three or four decades before they
had to be completely destroyed
and rebuilt from the ground up.
The end result was a persistent,
widespread practice that lasts to this day.
The quality of today’s homes, of course,
hardly resembles those of 1950. There’s
no reason any built this decade, if well cared
for, couldn’t survive well beyond thirty years.
But because they’re valued like fragile consumer
goods, owners have little incentive to put in the
necessary maintenance, turning the 30-year
lifespan into a self-fulfilling prophecy.
Meanwhile, until 2015, homeowners had little
incentive to demolish any houses they weren’t
living in thanks to another legacy of World
War II. Also to increase the supply of housing,
small residential plots were taxed 80%
less if they contained a structure.
That 1,400-square-foot home from earlier would
be taxed at just $75 a year, for example.
It’s exactly these kinds of seemingly
minor historical details that shape the
cities we live in today, and in “Great Cities”,
Dave from City Beautiful explains how,
for Shanghai, Canberra, and Paris.
Great Cities, like my six-part series “China,
Actually”, along with dozens of others, on topics
like urbanism, politics, and modern history, are
exclusively available on today’s sponsor, Nebula.
Signing up to Nebula is the absolute best way
to support independent creators like PolyMatter,
and the cheapest way to get access is
with the CuriosityStream bundle using
the link in the description. After signing up
to CuriosityStream for just $15 bucks a year,
you’ll get an email with instructions
on how to get free access to Nebula.
On CuriosityStream you can watch
feature-length documentaries,
like this one about how a single
bridge forever changed Japan.
Click the link on screen right now to get both
Nebula and CuriosityStream for
a mere fifteen dollars a year.